so as i've told you before even when you
hear populist rhetoric from the right it
often is followed up by the worst policy
ideas or blame games
sometimes fox news propagandist tucker
carlson
sounds like a populist not that
different from bernie sanders
in rhetoric except in the next breath
tucker will warn you black lives matter
might steal your house
and so you need our version of
right-wing populism to protect you from
that or
it'll be immigrants will steal he'll
sound like bernie and then say
uh immigrants are making us a dirty poor
country which he has said before
and very often let's be frank guys uh it
it is a very sp it is hanukkah very
often the tropes
go to the jews the anti-semitic tropes
will bubble up
in the most unexpected or maybe expected
places if you know what's going on
and that's where tucker went with a
segment a couple of nights ago
he starts with the perfect lead-up
to blaming jews which is to talk about
people
conspiring to secretly control you if
i've ever heard a good
premise for an anti-semitic trope it's
that take a listen to this welcome to
tucker carlson tonight we paid close
attention to a number of big elections
recently
but it turns out that many of the most
important elections are the ones you
hear
nothing about the news media barely
covers them
most voters don't know they're happening
as a result of this
a small group of committed extremists
gets to control the outcome
of those elections often with disastrous
results it happens all the time
and who is one of those people secretly
conspiring to control you
and others well of course it's old rich
jewish guy george soros this
is uh this is beyond parody now
but that's where tucker is going with
this check it out
it's not democracy as we were taught it
yet increasingly it's how things work
here
george soros understands that soros has
an eye for vulnerabilities
he became extraordinarily rich by
finding ways to exploit the weaknesses
in systems that he did not himself build
in the early 1990s soros became a
billionaire by shorting the british
pound crushing the bank of england in
the process
he went on to repeat those tactics and
other financial crises in countries
around the world
and then george soros turned his
attention to the united states where he
decided he would fundamentally change
our society it's actually amazing that
for all of the dressed up populist
rhetoric
and man of the people stuff and smart
conservative tucker carlson who doesn't
play the games republicans play
he's back to blaming george soros for
our problems disguised
with the same anti-semitic tropes that
we've been seeing for 150 200 years at
this point
and he continues with this check it out
if you're wondering why so many people
are being
robbed raped and killed in american
cities right now
george soros is part of the reason for
that soros has funded the campaigns of
left women's
extremists in district attorney races
all over the country
in cities like philadelphia st louis
chicago boston
traditionally a prosecutor's job is to
enforce the law
but soros wanted rigid ideologues who
would refuse to do that
and instead let murderers and rapists go
free while allowing our society itself
to degrade and collapse people are being
robbed
raped and killed because of george soros
how did you not know that now you know
how i've been saying that in all
likelihood
the return of a normal person to the
white house in joe biden
means everybody goes back to the normal
playbook republicans go back to
pretending to care about the deficit
and these faux populists on the right go
back to blaming the jews
or brown immigrants for everything it's
the same old playbook
this is an anti-semitic trope that goes
back centuries the rich jew
using subterfuge to control others and
manipulate society almost like a puppet
master
behind the curtain controlling the
marionettes for personal gain
it's just anti-semitism guys it's it's
well-disguised
sometimes anti-semitism but that's all
it is
when the right talks about george soros
it's code for the jews george soros is
just a rich 90 year old who survived the
nazi occupation of hungary
before moving to the united kingdom
after world war ii
but he's become code for he's become
emblematic
of the jews and most of them know they
can't
say the jews so they say george soros
it's a meme and it's a dog whistle and a
very obvious one at that
to many of us but it still gets by a lot
of the fox news audience now i know that
some of you will say
david there is no evidence that tucker
is personally anti-semitic
if if that's where your head is at this
point
then i probably can't rescue you but as
we've seen with donald trump as the
perfect example
it's less about the personal beliefs
about
jewish people or hispanic people or
black people or whoever
but it's about playing into the tropes
and fomenting these ideas repetitively
that that's actually what this is about
arguing about what's deep inside tucker
or trump's minds
uh uh that that's that's significantly
less important but right on cue
everybody going back to the standard
playbook and the roles we would expect
them to have
during a more normal administration
this episode is sponsored by bluechew
one of the things i make a priority on
the show is not to perpetuate
stigma for things that don't deserve it
we've talked about mental health we've
talked about many things where we should
all
just be respectful adults period and we
would be better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com
blue like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda approved
ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night
even on a full stomach since it's
chewable blue chew is prescribed online
by licensed doctors you don't have to go
to a doctor's office
you don't have to wait in line at a
pharmacy it ships right to your door in
a discreet package
they're made in the usa and since
bluetooth prepares and ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluechew.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
pay just five dollars shipping that's
blue
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free
bluechu is the better cheaper faster
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
david pakman show